働かなくても高い報酬を払うような会社
作ったらダメな人間を作れるんだよ。で、
その支質っていうのは人それぞれの支質が
あるんですよ。比べちゃいけないのよ。
組み合わせっていうことをすごく僕は大事
にしてるんですよ。フォアザチームなん
[音楽]ですよ。青木サトの人生警鉄学
100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今日の質問は青木社長いつも貴重なお話を
ありがとうございます。私は30代後半の
ベンチャー企業経営者です。社員はまだ
30年ほどですが、事業の拡大に伴い最近
人の配置の重要性を通感しています。誰を
どのポジションに置くかでチーム全体の
パフォーマンスがまるで変わってしまい、
配置ミスをすると優秀な人材が宝のモチさ
れ状態になってしまうリスクも感じますが
、人地配置を決定する上で見るべき要素が
多すぎて混乱してしまいます。年談では
前向きな発言をしていても実際に任せて
みると力を発揮できないこともあり見極め
が甘かったと感じることもしばしばです。
青木社長は社員の強みを最大化できる配置
を見極める際どんな点に重視されています
か?またその判断を謝らないために普段
からどんな観察や対話を心がけて
いらっしゃるのかお聞かせいただけると
嬉しいですと。
ま、これはね、一応一績でね、身につく
もんじゃないんですよ。まさに経験の中
から、ま、身につけてきたものなんですね
。ただ1つ明確に言えることは私は
シンプルに長所進展法です。人のいい
ところを見抜く。ここはキラりと光る彼の
いいとこだと。その良いところを最大限に
伸ばしてあげようと。これが私のまず基本
的な人事。の考え方ですね。弱点というか
欠点を見てあいつはここがダメだから
ちょっと信用できないなていう考え方では
なくて、ま、基本的にはポジティブにここ
がいいところだと。だからここを伸ばして
あげようと。で、ここを補うためには
こっちの人間をここにつけることによって
いいチームになる。で、お互いのいい
ところを出せば最強のチームができる。
そういう考え方だよね。だから組み合わ
せっていうことをすごく僕は大事にしてる
んですよ。チームだよね。フォアザチーム
なんですよ。だから人はですね、スーパー
マンじゃないのよ。自分も含めて欠点は
あるし、足りないところもあるし、苦手な
ところもあるし、でもそれをなるべく
カバーできるような組織運営をする。
やっぱり支出なんだよね。私は基本的には
支出論者です。農力開発の専門家なのに。
え、あなた教育の専門家じゃないですか?
私は支出を磨くタイプなんですよ。支出が
ないなと思ったら配置転換します。あの
支出がないのにいくらそこで頑張らせても
本人が腐っちゃうだけですよ。逆に言うと
用出
が1番大事なの。で、その支質っていうの
は人それぞれの支出があるんですよ。比べ
ちゃいけないのよ。例えば物を作って売っ
て管理する。この3つの大きなね、会社の
役割の中で作るのが得意な人っていうのは
やっぱり、ま、はっきり頭脳労働者という
かすごく頭がいいとクリエイティビティが
あると想像性があると企画力があると
やっぱりそれ想像力の働く人間と想像力の
働かない人間がいるんですよ。想像力には
2つの想像力がある。クリエイティビティ
というものを0からね、0中のまさに
作り出していく方のクリエイティビティ、
想像性と合成的想像力という組み合わせて
問題解決してくような想像力、
プランニングを立てるとかこれも全部未来
のことを考える。で、その想像力の不足し
てる人が経営者向いてないですよ。だから
プランニング立てれるか立てれないかって
いうのは、ま、ある意味でプランニングを
しっかり立てられる人間になるために経験
って必要なんだけど経験積んでもプランを
立てられない人間は経営者向きではないわ
な。だから職人で独立して会社が大きく
ならない人っていうのは事業計画のところ
でその組織的に配置を含めて適書で用る
ことができないのともっと言うと人の採用
の段階で支出の高い人間を集められないん
ですよ。これは会社大きくならないです。
だからいや難しいんだよ。でもこれだから
まずはね順番があって経営者自身が何者か
なのよ。天から与えた才能はもちろんある
と思うんですよ。ただおぎと生まれてから
どんな環境で育つかだから僕はね本当に
逆境が僕にとっては恵みだったと思うん
ですね。雪の心身降る中新聞配達をした僕
。あれはね、トップセールス妖精講座新聞
配達バージョンと思ってるわけよ。だ
からってね、何も頑張らなくてもね、報酬
が入るような状態っていうのは生け物にし
ちゃうよね、人を。だから人をダメにする
には働かなくても高い報酬を払うような
会社作ったらダメな人間を作れるんだよ。
だから政党に評価してあげること。私は
やっぱり支出かける環境をかける本人の
選択というこの方程式を持ってるので
支出る環境の中にはま人事制度から会社の
文化からで実はこれは非常に大事なテーマ
で環境って言うと物質的なものや自分の
いわゆる居住空間的なイメージを持つんだ
けどもちろんそれもあるんだけど1一般の
環境って付き合ってる人なんですよ。だ
から会社ってね、優秀な人間の塊にしとか
ないと安易にダメな人間をいっぱい入れる
とダメな環境を経営者が作ってることに
なるんだよ。だから経営者がいくらね
増えふけど踊らず。それなぜなら求めてる
ものが違うのと人事制度そのものがその
働く人の望みを叶えるようになっていない
。豊かになれないような仕組みになって
いる。年列型のね、収支雇用制度だとか
もう今時代合いません。そういうやり方は
。だから私はそうではなくて政党に評価し
てあげて私はね、いつ人生の幕を閉じたと
しても悔いのない人生、悔のない障害を
全倒しようと思って生きているので社員も
そうあって欲しいと思ってます。だから
毎日1日1勝、その日を最後の日として
生きる。そういう気持ちでベストを尽くし
て250人弱の人間が日々最善を尽くして
たら会社は発展して当たり前なんですよ。
だから人それぞれの良いところを見抜いて
長所進展法で敵材適書いいところを伸ばし
てちゃんとその人の強みが生かされる場所
にその配置をしてあげてであとは人は
スーパーマンじゃないから弱点もあるので
チームでそれを補っていけるようなそして
チーム全体のパフォーマンスが上がれば
生徒にそれを分配してあげるそういう感謝
なんだよね。分配イコール感謝なんですよ
。そういう仕組みを作っていったら政成
発展の法則という松下之さんのおっしゃる
自然の理法ってやつですよね。それが
やっぱり宇宙の営波なんだと私は思って
いるのでみんなが生かされる組織体を作り
たいと思って今まで努力をしてきました。
ま、人を慎重に採用して最大限に生かして
、え、そして今の利益30億の利益を
生み出せる組織体を作り上げてきました。
で、こっからなんだよね。でもうちはこっ
からさらに伸びるんですよ。実は私の
イメージでは創業から38年経って今
ようやくここまで来たの。こっからが
てんてんてんてんてんてんなんですよ。だ
からもう将来はうちはもう入りたくても
入れないぐらいのクオリティの高い会社に
なります。この文化を維持できればね。僕
が大事にしてるのは文化ですから当たり前
の基準が人を育てるのでそういうことなん
じゃないかな。うん。ありがとうござい
ます。
少々進展法で考えると本人がこうやりたいと強く希望する仕事よりも、ま、客観的にそれが向いてないとしたら向いてる仕事や部将にこう、ま、配置転換をしていくということが求められるのかなと思った時にこの
社員への伝え方ってありますか?
まあ、やっぱり本人をよまず観察をして、あ、こういうところいいとこだな。だからその関心を持たなきゃだめだよね、社員に。
で、よく見てて、ま、例えば早期を社長室
に抜擢したのもそうじゃん。早期に
アポ取りさせたらもったいないよ。やり
切ると思いますよ、責任感で。でもそこで
パーソナルコンサルタントで一生懸命
頑張ってできなくはないと思うんだよ。だ
けどだよ。
やっぱり頭を使う仕事とか会社の未来を企画してく仕事とかやっぱり責任を持たされて若くても今いくつなった?
26、27か。
27ですね。27だろ?27で今この
YouTube
の責任を持って僕の後はその書籍のね、例えば最終現稿のチェックをするとかね。
で、ま、早期も僕もそうだけど、ま、家庭
環境的にはちょっと特殊な、ある意味では
家庭環境を育ってるから、1番早期が強く
持ってるものはミッションですよ。
コミッションじゃないんだよ。だから、あ
、この子はミッションがあるなと、信用
できるなと、裏切らないなと。よし、投資
してあげようと。
で、そういう意味ではキャリアを積ませてあげたいと思うからどんどん抜擢して仕事を与えてあげる。今
ぐらいのプロジェクト色々持ってるだろ
ね。リーダーキッズやったりことやってきた。でもそのやってきたことをちゃんと自分で責任持ってで早期のいいところっていうのはなんだ安受け合いをしない。
できない時はできないって言うし、それ
から今自分が使える資源はこれだけでこれ
だけの時間ですけれどもこれをやるとなっ
たらこれを犠牲にしなければならなくなる
可能性がありますけど社長それでもいい
ですかとかはっきりとそれがやっぱり責任
感なんだよね。だ僕は責任感のある人間を
抜擢するんですよ。責任感のない人間だな
と思ったら責任感のある人間の下につけて
手足になる。作業型人材ですよね。作業型
人材は作業型人材の良さがあるわけだよ。
忠実であればいいんだよ。なぜなら頭の
いいやつが考えた通り実行さしてくれいい
んだから。で、これを実行しなかったら
今度は契約者になるんよな。実行力不全は
絶対勘弁しないんで僕は。は金なりで時間
は時間の中に溶け込むんだからその事業の
中で回収しなきゃいけないじゃん。てこと
はその回収するためには実行なんだよ。だ
僕は1番何大事にしてるかっていう実行
ですよ。だ判断力、リーダーシップ能力
実行力がうちの会社で上に上がる3大条件
だよね。だ判断力がなくてリーダーシップ
がなくて実行力なかったら何十年務めて
いってもうちは上に上がれないよ。それが
世の中の会社って年列で長くいれば年を
取っただけで上に上げてくじゃん。だから
ダメなんだよ。それはその経営者経営
分かってません。経営とは何か?お客様に
対する責任を全倒することですよ。
ちょっと力入ってきた。また問題発言し
とったから俺この辺で蓋するわ。うん。
プロっと出るからさ。うん。いや、そう
いうことだからやっぱり人を生かす経営を
人経営
やっぱり大事にした方がいいね。うん。す
と見えてきますよ。その人のいいところが
。そういうことだと思います。
はい。ま、支出をまずよくしっかり見る。
それからその支出を伸ばす環境を整える。
そして、ま、経営者自身がやっぱり
ちゃんと1人1人ね、この人材はと思う
人材には目をかけて育てる。やっぱり自分
の経験値をちゃんと伝えながら判断基準を
育てる。それから明確な目的目標に向かっ
て達成型人材に育てていく。そういうこと
が私は大切なことだと思います。そして、
え、失敗という言葉はないんですね。全て
経験しかありません。だから挑戦と挫折。
それを乗り越えて成長があり、その先に
サクセスがある。だから人を育てるという
ことはある意味で失敗ということを恐れ
させないような環境を作るっていうことが
人を育てる秘訣だと思います。ま、私は、
ま、うちの会社の文化そのものが
アグローリッチ哲学の企業文化だし、それ
とチョイスセオリーでやっぱりこう人と
比較しない自分の思考を現実化する。そこ
に1人1人を主人公とするそういう経営を
しているので、ま、おかげ様で今私は
すごく楽な経営者です。ま、できたらね、
この3日間のコースに来てもらえると、え
、この深いところのエッセンスを3日間
連続で私話しきるんで、この10分とか
20分のYouTubeじゃなくて3日間
ですから是非ね、来てもらえると人材育成
のポイントとかも掴んでいただけると思い
ます。え、是非ね、え、よろしくお願いし
ます。え、何か気づいたこと、感じたこと
あったら、え、コメント欄に是非コメント
ください。また、え、チャンネル登録まだ
してない方はしていただけると嬉しいです
。もうすぐ10万人です。よろしくお願い
します。また次回のYouTubeで会い
ましょう。ありがとうございます。
僕は元々トップセールス、トップ
マネージャー、トップコンサルタントで
確かに社員5名金500万で会社
マンションオフィスからスタートしたけど
企業家として燃えるような願望があって
16時間働いても疲れないだけの体力と
気力と強い願望と学校歴もなかったしも
なかった。だけど燃えるような願望はあっ
たんだよ。で、燃えるような願望がある
から賢くなるのよ。つまりその燃えるよう
な願望故えに素直にもなるし、人の力も
活用できるし、燃えるような願望がある
からこれを成し遂げるためには人の力を
借りなければいけない。人は何を求めてる
かって言うと、経済的豊かさと精神的豊か
さを求めてる。じゃあそれを与えられる
ようにちゃんと前持って準備をしよう。
準備をしてからお願いをしよう。もしくは
その価値を作り出せる仕事を一緒になって
作り出していく中で正当に貢献に対しては
シェアをしよう、分かち合おう。こうやっ
て会社を大きくしてきて今正社員250人
弱のね組織になって、ま、平均報酬もうち
は今680万ぐらいですよ。社員の平均
報酬ね。ま、大企業に肩を並べるだけの
少しレベルになってきた。でも、じゃあ
例えばキエンスだとかね、いろんな会社と
の全く異業種のところと比べた時に、
まだまだうちはレベルがまだ低い。ま、
外食だとか他の産業と比べた時は報酬は
高いけれど理想っていうのは私の中にある
んですよ。なぜかわかんないけど僕は
800万の平均年収にしたいの。なぜか
わからない。それなぜかわからないって
どういうことかって言うと、業界の平均と
かじゃないのよ。これは自分のプライドで
解消持ちになりたいわけね。解消っていう
のは縁ある人を豊かにできる人間と僕は
定義してるんですよ。まず家族を豊かにし
、社員を豊かにし、お客様を豊かにし、
社会を最後は豊かにできる人間になりたい
と思って、ま、32歳から一生懸命努力し
てきて、今70歳になってるわけだ。でも
事実、ま、うちの研修受けてくれた人たち
みんな豊かになってるよね。まず心が豊か
になるでしょ。人間関係の問題が解決し、
仕事に対する意味付け、意付けが明確に
なり、働く人たちも誰のために何のために
なぜ仕事してるのかというちゃんと
意味付け、意付けができる教育者に経営者
が変わるから。として共に歩んでいく中で
、ま、結果的に豊かな人生をみんなが遅れ
ている。
[音楽]
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容そのものに惚れ込ん
でるかどうかです。
[音楽]